natürlich bereue ich das sonst werde ich
diesen schritt nicht gehen können das
ist ganz ganz wichtig ist das ist
vielleicht das hinten runtergefallen um
das mal klarzustellen ja also ich hab
auch der opferfamilie auch im brief
geschrieben das war mir persönlich sehr
wichtig der leider denn auch in der
presse gelangt ist auch bei ihnen in der
zeit unglaublich in der bild zeitung war
deren entscheidung aber trotzdem ist
natürlich reue und es auch empathie in
dem sich gespräch das auch in meinem
buch was jetzt herauskommt weiß wofür
sie eine art therapie ja na klar aber
die hat doch schon vorher stattgefunden
dadurch dass er prozesse wirklich so
lange die leute lief hatte ich ja sehr
viel zeit ja auch zwangsläufig mit mir
auseinander zu setzen und da habe ich
mich schon maximal glaube ich auch
selbst therapiert weil man muss auch
dazu sagen dass es über jedem wichtigen
bei jedem spielsüchtigen was auch immer
die die erkenntnis muss erstmal selbst
anfangen sonst bringt das nichts das
breite ab ja ja ist gut und dann geht es
wie sie es schon sagen bricht das dann
wieder aus also nicht wenn die krankheit
aber mit wieder rückfällig wie auch
immer
[Musik]